Luke was lyin a writing assignment for
you how're you pitched the screenplay I
had a previous relationship with the
producers seif see saw films because one
of those producers Emile Sherman had
produced a film that I wrote candy with
Heath Ledger 10 years earlier so we had
a prior relationship basically and a
professional and an affection and a
respect and friendship are so they came
to me here's this book what do you think
that was how it happened and I read this
book and I was like what do I think this
is like a beautiful fairy tale with
elements of nightmare and redemptive
qualities it's like a myth and like what
I think is I really hope that I get this
job i'm going to try and write a
structure and I hope I'm the one you
guys want and and I got it and then it
was really fast Luke congratulations you
got the job jump on a plane so ruse in
India you're going to India he's going
to show you all the real places where
everything happened the train station
the orphanage he's home town the damn
the station the platform the rain tank
and most of all I met his mother his
biological mother and spent a few hours
with her which was an extraordinary
experience so you'd never heard of the
book or suru story previously well by
coincidence the that the book came out
when the book came out there were
articles about it online and in the four
days or so before that phone call when
they said can you check this book and
tell us what you think i had read the
story so there was this tiny little
moment where I said oh I read about that
this week that's kind of an amazing
story the guy the Google Earth thing so
there's a really vague thing where I had
glanced at something that was kind of
just this viral like thing that you
glance at like that that's kind of cool
and then four days later they were like
we've got this book you know about this
story so yeah I did I knew about it this
much so when you meet someone that
you'll be essentially duplicating their
life on screen and I'm sure all the
pressures that go along with that what
questions are you asking them or are you
merely just observing them it it wasn't
like I had a prepared set list of
questions like so I'm about to sort of
rape and pillage your
life and steal your psyche and do this
thing and but it also wasn't like
observational it was like this it was
like a really interesting intense three
week two or three-week research trip
where I spent a week and a half with him
going around India and then we flew to
Tasmania and I met his adoptive parents
and the places that he grew up in Hobart
and so on so it wasn't just
observational it was actually just a lot
of down time we just getting to know
someone and interacting I mean it
literally became like okay so I'll see
you I see you here for breakfast or like
so we want to meet down here for dinner
with all the down time things between
the scheduled stuff which was like
tomorrow we're going on the train from
here to here to see what the trains are
like and then we're going to the
orphanage and we're doing this where
that was all very but the other thing
was just pleasantly getting to know this
guy who's really he's an unusually
self-possessed guy you know I think the
vast majority of us are on some sort of
scale where we like to be liked we'd
like to get on with other people and we
have social contracts about how we
behave and so on saru is weirdly like
you can really tell he doesn't care what
other people think about him and I think
that's because he had such a one in a
zillion extraordinary experience of
compressed trauma at an age where it
shouldn't have happened to anyone that
it turned him into a certain kind of
human being that has this self-contained
thing and doesn't need the approval of
other in order to sort of survive he's
he's in her life a really interesting
thing is that whenever he's with Sue
this is my observation his mother his
adoptive mother it's like a lock that
opens this door where he's closer to
that vulnerable bewildered frightened
five-year-old boy so it's kind of like
he grew up he only had five years in
India then he became a really aww gee I
some of that means you're a bit of a lad
shut down Australian males he
never like not to in touch with your
emotions or whatever and he's a little
bit of that but he's also a guy who had
one of the most emotional sort of mythic
stories that you could experience so
he's got all that within him
and his beautiful adoptive mother sue is
like the doorway to that where you see
suru change when he's with her because I
think she's just so deeply part of the
journey of where he came from and where
he got to how many people have you met
that have been similar like that in
terms of self-contained that you can
just tell their they're almost their own
Island when they're in a public setting
I've met no one like suru he's he's
there's something really unusual about
his um he's bearing and i know and i
don't mean he's cut off he's really
friendly he's really funny he's our he's
full of one liners he's a very wry
observer of human foibles he's extremely
charming it's like he just you know he
can sweep the ladies off their feet you
know what I mean his favorites these are
interesting qualities he came out of
this place that was pure survival and
peril you know he's spoken about that
people ask him about his emotions as a
five-year-old he's like wait emotions
were a luxury for that period of time I
had to have a hired as thick as an
elephant hide skin and what was going on
was second by second black and white yes
no left right decisions emotions were
like far far away in that situation I
think some of his journey was about
suppressing the trauma of that and then
for 25 years because he landed in this
beautiful deal with his beautiful people
and John and Sue are beautiful people
they always had the vision where go
there are enough children suffering in
the world we're going to adopt children
we're not going to have our own children
that was like their vision in life and
they stuck to it but but and so suru had
that deep that in his background and so
he kept it a secret that all those years
he dreamed every night he imagined kind
of like astral travelling back to India
to get back to his mother and brother
and to say I'm here I'm sorry I got lost
you know its inquiry when I just to say
those words I'm sorry I got
it's so touching because it wasn't his
fault what happened it's one of the
movie one of the things that makes the
movie so intensely beautiful because it
wasn't his fault he was just really
vulnerable and he made one single
decision he stepped on a train and and a
catastrophe began that completely
changed his life that ended up being
okay but it wasn't okay while it was
happening and so yeah that makes him
that's part of what makes him so so
different from the rest of us right I've
seen a few interviews and I definitely
see that quality in him and I would
imagine he would be very good at sort of
reading emotions because that's probably
at the base of it how he survived it's a
survival skill right yeah you got to get
really good at reading people such as
the scene in the movie with the the you
know who is that guy is he a child sex
trafficker and saru has said maybe I'm
wrong I might have been misreading that
situation but I don't think so and
you're basically like yeah none of us
think so either you weren't miss reading
that situation right and the way you set
it up too because the woman was so you
thought always finally found someone he
can trust yeah but I don't wanna give
away too much here yeah so when you
finally sat down to assemble the script
are you consulting with him or is it
becoming a finished product and then
saru here you go or none of that yeah it
was more the latter it was so then so
that was really handy to meet him to
travel around with him to get a sense of
who he was and then it was like so now
I'm in this place with goth then Garth
and I came together so now it's about
your loyalty towards trying to create a
film that is a rollicking good yarn
gripping compelling and in yes of course
at the same time having a kind of moral
and ethical duty towards the fact that
you're dealing with real people's lives
very much still alive but he wasn't part
of that process then until it was like
here's the script and what was really
surprising was that he's basically his
reaction was it was kind of like oh ok
cool so this is what a script is like
that's interesting I didn't know this is
what a screenplay looks like all these
technical things that you got to work
out what does that mean
exterior you know day you know all that
technical stuff he didn't actually have
a lot to say about well that didn't
happen or that didn't happen or I feel
uncomfortable about that there was very
very little sue his mother for example
said I thought you should have made the
orphanage staff darker oh we thought
that often in scenes were pretty damn
dark what's going on in there is you
know very troubling and unpleasant some
aspects of it not mrs. sued the
wonderful lady who comes and rescues him
obviously yeah but no sir was just like
okay I get it we at through and his mum
and dad John and Sue I mean they were
like we understand that not everything
is exactly like what happened but we are
completely touched by your capturing of
the emotional truth of the story and the
stuff that we tweaked they understood
that too that they were learning about
decisions you have to make in filmmaking
okay like for example trivial level in
real life saru basically drove three
girlfriends crazy in his five year
search for home you know we've got the
it's much better to have Rooney Mara one
character not three we don't we didn't
need three girlfriends to try to tell
the same story and he was like ah okay
ah so that's the kind of thing you do in
film making decisions that's cool do you
remember how many pages his book a long
way home was it's a medium sized book
Mike I'm guessing 220 pages what kind of
thing like that and then some of the
first or earlier drafts of the script
how many pages were those how are you
willing it down ah I had I've written
some first drafts of other scripts that
are crazy long way you're just getting
it all down we we honed the treatment
and the plan so tightly that my the very
first draft very first full draft of
lion was only like 125 pages and that's
like raw and within a week I had that
down to 115 and it kind of landed at 104
or something like that after all the ups
and downs and this scene goes and this
new scene comes in
over that period of the the next few
drafts before it became a shooting
script a lot of stuff changed but wasn't
like going from this to this yeah it was
being refined but it was never a big
messy first draft because we got all our
messiness and agony out of the way with
the treatment and the work though it was
a it was an extremely dense detailed
treatment I was like a 40-page treatment
that was like literally beat by beat
scene by scene yeah so you're dealing
with human beings but then you're also
dealing with Google Earth which is a
completely other you know Rama how much
research are you doing in to Google
Earth how familiar had you already been
with the program I didn't personally
have to I was really familiar with the
program when Google Earth came out I too
like many people went to my childhood
home and worked out and memories came
flooding back you know that was the
creek where I used to play with my
brothers and Owen at all these houses
that used to be bushland and all of that
you know I did that and but like so at a
script writing level what I knew was
that we had this tale that felt like an
ancient tale like it felt like an
ancient myth or an ancient fairy tale
that goes back to the earliest origins
of like humans storytelling you know
like reunification with the lost mother
and yet this was a story that in the
whole history of human civilization
could never have happened until 10 years
ago until google released google earth
we wouldn't be sitting here right now if
that app had not been released because
he could never have found home the way
he did with these four or five or six
visual memories that he need to
basically geo locate from space and so
to me it was like oh my god it's an old
myth and a new myth and so what a
beautiful challenge to get that in there
and if we handle the first half of the
film really well if we're inside the
reality and the distress and peril and
bewilderment and fear and determination
of this five-year-old boy then in the
second half when it gets more interior
and psychologically we're going to
experience that as being exactly the
same person on an unfinished interrupted
journey the interruption happens to be
25 years but we should be feeling like
wearing the same person
and and it's and the technology it's not
like most films where technologies like
logistical kind of plot development
stuff the the liberation for us was that
we knew that the technological stuff the
Google Earth stuff is part of the
emotional journey so that you hopefully
the audience you feeling it in your gut
basically but at the level of research I
didn't have to do much I just tried to
write the Google stuff poetically this
is what he's seeing on screen this is
what he's seeing on screen this is what
he's seeing on screen because I trusted
that she saw the great company and that
they'll work out the tech details
properly and what happened was they had
very little to do with Google Earth
except that the Google Earth coding guys
helped make the Google screen stuff
completely authentic and period
authentic from the actual times that
saru was searching so they went in this
guy described it to me we went to Google
headquarters all of us it was really fun
day and he described it as the
archaeology of the coding they had to go
in like archaeologists to the coding of
the earlier versions of Google and they
weren't sure if they would succeed in
properly recreating what Google Earth
was like at any given time and they got
it down to fine detail they worked out
the timelines of when Sarah was looking
at so if you're a tech geek it's
completely authentic every single time
you see google earth on screen in the
film it tracks the time of when Sarah
was actually searching the stuff in the
very beginning it's the super slow
buffering speeds through remember the
frustrations of the early days of Google
Earth now it's great and it was the low
resolution when you zoom down to the low
levels and so on so they recreated that
it's kind of cool like it's cool in a
sort of i whisk you need to know the
tech stuff way yeah had you talked to
anyone else or had you personally done
any like journey back home to confront
any sort of like memories or anything
and all that goes through that for
someone because it's a different a trip
than someone who maybe has fond memories
it's much more emotional yeah well that
the thing you know it's a
one-in-a-million kind of story because
this hasn't happened to most of us I
have continuity from childhood
with my parents and brothers and sisters
and loved ones that even that means i
don't have there's not an unexplained
emotional journey if I've understood
your question correctly that I had to go
back and experience so I had to use my
imagination I just had to have my own
memories and interestingly enough Google
Earth going back to my childhood Street
was vividly incredible in terms of
memories of being five years old when we
moved into that Street I was three years
old so I don't have memories of the
house before that from 0 to 3 I only
have memories of that street that house
and they and they and they're really
really vivid and Google Earth was like
oh my god that's the street that's the
curve that's where we did that that's
where we played it you know this and
that and arm and I had to use the leaps
of the imagination to think man could at
five years old could I have done any of
this no food no money no clothes no
nothing anal in a world full of perils
and predators have hell and also we live
in a us you me everybody we live in
first world countries where if five year
old kids are wandering around the street
distressed it gets dealt with pretty
quickly this does not happen in India
there are bands of feral street kids and
if they try and harass any adults they
get batted away it's just it's the way
of life it's the chaos it's the poverty
it's the extraordinary other worldliness
of India that is so not what what we
know our privileged first world reality
and Sensibility so the leap of the
imagination into what that must have
been like is immense and for me it's
just hats off to garth davis the
director because he made that leap he
brought it to life it's like my script
was just this way station at the
beginning of the process but to me he
did such a beautiful job that when i
watched the movie now even though i
wrote it and I know what happens every
second i cry everytime i watch it
because I'm I'm an observer of goths
beautiful work of art you know and he
created all these magic moments that
took the leap of the imagination and
make you feel what it's like to be in
such danger and
and trying to survive did you take any
train rides either by yourself in India
or with the masses of we see in one
scene where it just looks overwhelming
yeah well I did we went to how are our
station the main station where saru got
spat out in Calcutta and that was
amazing for research also that's the
station where they shot all the scenes
so that the real place is the place
where it really happened about up in
madhya pradesh province I the home
village yeah we went on like a four hour
train ride and back just to get a sense
just for my research it was like I
wanted to get a sense of the chaos of
the trains and the seating arrangements
and the structures just to help with
basic technical stuff of how to write
what's going on in the trains and what's
going on on the stations and the
fundamental thing of any travel
experience in India if you've been there
is that it is exhausting every single
thing is so kind of chaotic and I mean
maybe I'm sounding like a wimp here but
traveling in India is both exhilarating
and exhausting at every single level
from the smallest detail to the largest